alors vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
poursuivre dans cette voie face aux
nombreux défis que tu a rappelé qu'ils
sont devant nous je pense notamment à la
situation internationale mais aussi aux
défis climatiques et écologiques sur
lequel il faut agir plus vite et plus
fort et je suis convaincu que nous
pourrons le faire en associant encore
davantage les forces vives de nos
territoires parce que c'est bien au plus
près des français qu'on trouvera les
bonnes réponses et c'est bien tout le
sens aussi de la nouvelle méthode voulue
par le président de la république
alors comme vous l'imaginez je suis
évidemment très ému ce soir et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour la première femme qui a occupé ses
fonctions
edith cresson et peut-être je voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves et rien ne doit
freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société
monsieur le premier ministre cheikh gens
je pense sincèrement que vous êtes une
personne rare parce que vous privilégiez
toujours le collectif et que vous
incarnez ce qu'est un ministre ce qu'est
un premier ministre c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un qui sert son pays donc merci
très sincèrement ibra vous
[Applaudissements]